an Alabama man is expected to appear in
court today after new DNA technology
linked em to a decades-old double murder
case 45 year-old Koli mcrainey faces
charges in the 1999 killings of two high
school students tracy hall 'it and JB
Beasley investigators use the same
technique that led to the arrest of the
alleged Golden State killer Omar
Villafranca is here at the table that's
a rare thing for us to show us how
cracking dozens of cold cases how that's
working this new technology Omar is
really fascinating it is at the end of
you ever taking a home DNA test yeah
okay well if that what you mean by
spitting into the thing 23 and yeah yeah
if you do you have the option of
submitting your information to a public
database it's called Jen match now
hundreds of police departments are using
a combination of jet match and crime
scene DNA to track down family members
of possible suspects
I wake up and I hear her screaming Carol
Robert says she's had countless dreams
about her daughter Tracey haul it haul
it and JB Beasley were 17 when they got
lost on this Ozark Alabama Road in 1999
a memorial marks where their bodies were
found in the trunk of Beasley's car they
had been shot we haven't slept all night
in almost 20 years I don't care how many
times a night I wake up Tracey's on my
mind I remember like yesterday where I
was when I got a phone call about this
case it also stayed on the mind of
Marlo's Walker now Ozarks police chief a
few months ago he decided to see if old
evidence might lead to a new break in
the case what made you say let me see if
there's any DNA that we can process in
this case what really struck a heart
with me is when the Golden State killer
got caught and I just thought that why
not try to apply that to this case
alleged Golden State killer Joseph James
DeAngelo was arrested in 2018 after DNA
tied him to a series of decades-old
rapes and murders inspired by that case
chief Walker submitted the Ozark
evidence to Virginia based Parab on nano
labs to help find the suspect paraben
developed a genetic profile of a suspect
and then ran that information through a
public DNA database
jedd match para bonding created a
possible family tree and within months
chief walker had several new leads
walker called in who he thought was a
family member of a potential suspect
you told him I need a sample of your DNA
and he gave you a sample yes and you
sent that back to the company what did
it come back with he come out with a
positive when they told you it was a
match what was your reaction I just said
in my office in my period just thinking
the day's finally come and then I was
also surprised of who it was young man
has no criminal histories or anything
last month police arrested 45 year old
Coley McCraney McCray knees attorney
says his client is not guilty over 200
agencies have reached out to para bond
and asked us to analyze their cases see
see more is the chief genetic
genealogist at para bond and worked on
the ozark case para bond has helped
solve nearly 50 cold cases Moore says
the company's work generates leads we're
providing a highly scientific tip but no
one's going to be arrested based on what
we say alone law enforcement has to take
that tip and then go and build their
traditional forensic case against this
person Carol Roberts is still praying
for justice all I've ever wanted to do
was stand in front of someone one day
and ask him why why you thought you had
the right to take my daughter's life you
may get that day are you ready I think
the Lord will give me the strength to be
ready mcrainey
could face the death penalty now this
type of DNA evidence has not been
challenged in a trial yet the first case
is not in Alabama it's actually gonna be
in Washington State expected to be tried
in June I talked to a forensic expert
who expects defense attorneys to not
only challenge the crime scene DNA and
that integrity but also the proprietary
methods that periban uses to come up
with the leads and this expert also told
me basically judges and lawyers are not
scientists we have to see how it plays
out in court what works in a lab may not
work in a courtroom I'm surprised he
would give up his DNA Omar knowing that
he could possibly be tied to this case
what's interesting is that the police
said he recognized that name because he
went to high school with that guy Wow
so six degrees trying to get a family
tree connection maybe you got the root
wow thank you
really interesting